hello everyone
it's me your friendly youtube host dave
rubin today is december 4th
2020. this is the reuben report direct
message and i'm here and uh before we
get going today
someone who i like who i respect
uh not a public person just someone in
my private life
said to me yesterday they said dave you
know your shows have really been great
lately
and you're you seem to be uh telling the
truth and bringing information to the
people
but you've been using some colorful
language you've been
busting out your glasses you've been
dropping f-bombs you said
mf you've been saying some things
calling people
types of bags that start with a d you've
been saying these things
and i want to share these videos with my
more conservative
friends and family but if you do that
sort of stuff
it makes it hard for me to do so i
thought well look i can't
sell censor myself but i i do understand
that there is some legitimacy to that
and i would say in the last two weeks as
i live in this ridiculous state of
california in this particularly
ridiculous city of los angeles but i've
been a little more fired up than usual
and i've actually been enjoying it and i
think you guys have been enjoying it as
well
um but for today
i'm going to try not to curse i am not
going to say any mean language
i'm going to try to do it i'm going to
try to do it despite the fact that my
mayor
has me locked down in my home and i just
want to be on the record i am not having
a party
at my house tonight i just want to be
very clear about that
trust me i am not i want garcetti if
you're watching this
i'm not having a whole bunch of people
here for dinner tonight that is so not
happening
and i just you know why would you think
that's happening it's not
i'm not having people over i didn't buy
a whole bunch of food yesterday for a
party at my house tonight that's crazy
talk
uh okay so uh we're gonna hit a bunch of
stuff today uh we are going to play
in just a moment this video of joe biden
he did a love fest interview with jake
tapper
we're we're back to the part of politics
if biden is to become
president which again i'm still not sure
about and we'll talk about that in uh in
story number two
uh we're back to the part where the uh
the journalists the journalists
can just smile and nod along and and
be very chummy chummy with the
politicians that they're interviewing
and and
tapper and biden really did a number but
wait till biden
wait till you see this clip biden
accidentally tells the truth that's one
of the things he
sometimes does he accidentally tells the
truth well he did that so that's going
to be the first story
then the second story and i'm sure most
of you saw this already but i want to
discuss it a little bit
is there is a video that's going viral
right now
it has been seen hundreds of thousands
of times if not if not millions of times
at this point
from election night in georgia and there
is some strange stuff
caught on a camera in one of the rooms
where they're counting votes
after they said they stopped counting so
i'm going to put that video up there
and you it's from oan is where we
originally
got the video and you can see if you
think there's something there and
obviously
there are going to be lawyers and
forensic people and everything else
looking into it but again it's one of
those things where it's like something
doesn't seem right here
are we allowed to talk about it are you
going to put us on a list well i'm going
to talk about it
uh and then the third story we're doing
for today the third story
san diego which is about three hours
south here in uh
socal the unified school district is
forcing teachers to attend white
privilege training sessions and you and
they're literally teaching
about the book white fragility and it's
completely insane and we're going to
show you some of the slides that they're
showing some of the teachers
and then finally and i love that we're
ending on this story
uh i posted a video yesterday that on
twitter that everyone thought was my
video we didn't know where it originally
came from so we just grabbed it
it's from a store called kitson here in
los angeles which if
if you don't know kittson i don't even
know that they're actually open anymore
because who knows what's actually open
these days but kitson is sort of like a
high-end
urban outfitters and somebody went to
kitten in west hollywood it's about two
blocks from where i used to live a
couple years ago
and they did this incredible
stream of anti-democratic candidates and
and pelosi and and garcetti and newsom
and there are some just all of the
hypocrite hypocritical nonsense
that these people have been spewing they
just did these beautiful
window treatments uh with all of them so
we're going to show you that video it's
just
absolutely perfect and it makes me proud
to think that even here in this crazy
city of los angeles that that people are
standing up and i'd love to find out
who the owner of kitson is and like
what's going on there it's just it's
just something else
all right but let's jump into story
number one so joe biden
did a little interview with jake tapper
on
cnn the least trusted name in news
and uh in a fact tapper asked him well
what happens if you and kamala
disagree on things let's take a look
but all kid aside the first lady to be
told me she holds them for you yes she
does
but not with she's because she she and
camel have become friends
but all kidding aside it's it's a matter
of
the thing we are simpatico on our
philosophy of government
and simpatico on how we want to attach
approach these issues that we're facing
and so i don't have and when we disagree
it'll be just like
so far it's been just like when barack
and i did it's in private she'll say i
think we should do a b c
or d and i'll say i don't i like a don't
like b and c
and let's go okay but and i like i told
barack
if if if i reach something where there's
a a fundamental
disagreement we have based on a moral
principle
i'll uh i'll i'll i'll i'll develop some
disease and say i have to resign
um we don't have that i'm a we haven't
and we discussed at length
our views on foreign policy on domestic
policy on intelligence and
the great thing is she has a background
in the senate
on intelligence the intelligence
committee she has a background in the
senate on
a whole range of things that are going
to be pertinent to what we have to do
but it's going to be i think so much is
going to be incoming
jake it's a matter about who who takes
what when
that 78 year old man is the purported
president-elect of the united states now
let's just put aside the general
mumbling and sort of the way he meanders
around
everything he's saying and he never
quite gets there and uses a lot of extra
words and all that stuff
the line if he is to have a disagreement
with
kamala i'll develop some disease
and say i have to resign
now i get it he's kidding even though he
said all kidding aside right before that
but doesn't that feel like one of the
ones that's just like sitting in the
back of his head that they all kind of
know
is gonna happen here like we all kind of
know
and we know about how nancy pelosi was
already talking about using the 25th
amendment
before the election like they're already
setting the groundwork
that obviously this man is not going to
be president for four years and also if
he had a disagreement with kamala harris
he's the president so wouldn't she be
the one that would have to
resign not him right i get it he was
saying it in reference
to dealing with uh barack obama when he
was the vp but like that sort of like
accidental truth you guys probably also
remember that video
what was it about a month and a half ago
or so where he says that we are running
we the democrats are running the largest
voter fraud organization in american
history something to that effect
and it's like did he mean to say that no
why did he say it was it just sitting in
the back there like
there's something rotten in stinktown as
they would say
but the interview with jake tapper went
on
and uh joe loves masks joe really loves
masks and
let's take a look speaking of fouchy
uh have you spoken with him yet if so
have you asked him to stay on
yes he is yes yes and yes tell me about
the conversation
he said what more needs to be done from
his point of view well look
uh my chief of staff has worked with him
in the last
uh crisis he's been talking to him all
the time ron clayne i talked to him
today we spoke today three o'clock
my covetee met with him i asked him to
stay on in the exact same role he's had
for the past several presidents
and i asked him to be a chief medical
advisor for me as well
and be part of the coveted team and so
what has to be done
is we have to make it clear to the
american people
that the vaccine is safe when it
occurred when that is determined
and number two you have to make sure as
he points out
you don't have to close down the economy
like a lot of folks are talking about
now if in fact you have clear guidance
and you're able to say the business is
okay for example
bars and restaurants are going to close
we're going to provide you the
wherewithal
to not lose your business like we were
like the house had passed
and we're going to be able to reopen
we're going to be able to reopen in time
and not to
close down for long periods of time we
talked about masking
uh it is important that we in fact uh
the president and the vice president we
set the you know the
the the pattern by wearing masks but
beyond that
where the federal government has
authority i'm going to issue a standing
order that in federal buildings you have
to be masked and
in transportation interstate
transportation you must be massed in
airplanes and buses etc
and so uh it's it's a matter of
and i think my inclination uh jake is on
the first
day i'm inaugurated to say i'm going to
ask the public for 100 days
to mask just 100 days to mask not
forever 100 days
and i think we'll see a significant
reduction if we occur that
everything that occurs with vaccinations
and masking
to drive down the numbers considerably
all right so again we've got sort of the
mumbling and stammering the rest of it
let's just put that aside let's just
focus
on the last part there when he takes
office the first day he's going to ask
for a hundred more days
to wear a mask a hundred more days to
wear a mask now if he was to take office
that would be on january 20th 100 days
that's over three months that basically
gets us into may
um do you guys remember back in march do
you remember march it was a long time
ago
that was when we were told two weeks to
flatten the curve
we all did absolutely everything that
they asked
people stayed home people wore masks
people did not go
out people did not see other people we
have done
a multitude of versions of that in all
of the different states we have done all
of these things
and now a hundred days a federal mandate
a hundred days
to wear a mess do you realize this put
aside that it's not constitutional
it makes no sense at any level first off
the number hundred
oh it's oh 100 days will be fine so 98
days won't be fine
101 days no 100 i mean 100 it's a it's a
nice round number so 100 days
to wear a mask and then everything will
be fine sure we did tell you two weeks
to flatten the curve
last time but 100 days then we think we
can get this under control it's just
a made up number we also have something
called federalism
in the united states this is the idea
that states can make decisions for
themselves this is
this is one of the great beautiful
things that we have in the united states
that if you live somewhere that you
want to live then it is good and if you
don't want
to live there because you're under the
power of people you don't
like perhaps in los angeles where you're
locked down relentlessly you can move to
a place like florida this is a beautiful
thing
i often talk about the foot vote and you
can live in a place that's more in line
with your beliefs
the idea that things should be done
federally especially because this is
just arbitrary like if you think a
hundred days he has no scientific
evidence
a hundred more days guys which by the
way we're still about
what 40 or so days away from a day that
he would be inaugurated
so for just 140 more days from now
if we were wearing masks things would be
okay it's all
just made up nonsense again
you can figure out what to do in your
life
and then when you know he's talking
about all these other things well
federal buildings you'll wear a mask but
then in
bars we'll close bars but we'll give
them money it's all these things it's
like none of it really works the way
it's supposed to
people want to go back to work they want
to take a little bit of a risk it is not
the government's duty or responsibility
to protect you from everything there is
something else going on here that i
think has very little
to do with kovid and i'll just say one
other thing which
is if you want to prove me wrong then
show me numbers
show me numbers how in a place like
florida that is largely open or a place
in
like texas that is largely open show me
how their numbers are
so out of control compared to a place
like new york and california and you
know why you don't see those comparisons
because they don't exist they don't
exist
florida people are living their lives
again and making decisions for
themselves florida by the way which has
a fairly elderly population right people
go from the northeast
and from the middle of the country where
do they retire they retire to florida
because it's warm so you have an older
population that's
generally as you get older you get
sicker too so you'd think they'd be much
more high risk
yet florida has figured out a way to
open
so shouldn't their numbers be just
significantly i don't know two
three ten times higher than in places
where we've been in relentless endless
lockdown
like california and new york but you
don't see those comparisons do you and
the idea that the federal government is
supposed to be
in charge of the whole freaking thing
just makes no sense to me
at all uh but as long as we're talking
about uh oh no you know let's let's
let's move on from that because i think
you got the point i think you got the
point
on the covet stuff and again i am not
having people over for dinner and any
uh any accusation of such is
um that is just well i have lawyers okay
you understand what i'm saying
uh all right let's move on because uh
the election still
is not decided let's remember joe biden
is not technically
the president-elect there are court
cases going on all over the place from
pennsylvania to arizona
to georgia and elsewhere things are
actually working through the court i've
been trying to show you guys over the
last couple of weeks
without giving you hope of things that i
think are
unable to happen i've been trying to
just show you here's what's going on
here's what people are saying here's
what
sydney powell is saying here's what
giuliani's saying we showed the video
yesterday
of trump's lawyer saying that in arizona
they have 40 000
uh votes that were put in twice well
they said they were submitting that to
the court so now we'll find out and if
it turns out to be debunked then so be
it but these are things that are
happening
that you should know about right these
are accusations that you should know
about
uh so out of georgia uh this video went
viral
yesterday and into today it's still
going viral now we're gonna show you a
clip from oan and this is from security
footage
the night of the election and if you
remember the night election wasn't there
a pipe that burst somewhere in georgia
and they had to stop counting
and then suddenly like those seven
states that are all up in the air right
now
arizona pennsylvania etc georgia et
cetera
uh suddenly trump had leads in all of
them and then everybody stopped counting
at once
uh here's video from oam this is the
security footage and they're going to
give you a little bit of an explainer
and watch that black table that you're
going to see there and suddenly
uh ballot boxes being taken out from
that black table
and you tell me if you think this is
something so according to the witnesses
the republican observers
there is a lady who has blonde braids
who comes out to announce we're going to
stop
counting everyone go home
and in fact we see that what happens is
everyone clears out including the
republican observers in the press
but four people stay behind and continue
counting and tabulating
well into the night from that point
which is going
to be about 10 25 when they all clear
out or 10 30.
and they will continue counting
unobserved unsupervised
not in public view as your statute
requires
until about 1 in the morning the reason
we know this
is because when our republican observers
were forced to leave
they went to the central tabulation
center
and they got news from a word from a
news crew that in fact counting had
continued
they have information that not everybody
left according to plan
and some people stayed behind so this
shocked them so they returned back to
state farm arena at about one o'clock in
the morning
where they confirmed that in fact people
had just left
state farm arena and contravention of
what they've been told
by the supervisors who are running this
operation
okay so there's a lot there and i think
one of the problems with all of these
videos when you see these videos or you
hear the testimony and everything else
well first off people have lives and
some people still have jobs and it's
hard to just watch hour after hour of
testimony
and people that signed sworn affidavits
saying
with the threat in some cases going to
jail if they're caught lying
it's just hard to pay attention to all
of those things and it's like wait a
minute are you are you an
expert or just a regular person and
somehow they're a regular person that
seems less trustworthy like this whole
thing
is just messy on top of the layer of
course that we don't have a media that
that honestly talks about any of these
things but in essence what you are
seeing there
is after they said they were done
counting for the night suddenly these
these boxes of votes just appear out of
nowhere from under this table that does
seem
kind of odd well that now is evidence
and that will be presented in court and
we'll have to find out more
all i'm saying is it's worth being aware
that these things
are happening i know that makes a lot of
people very very angry
but i hope i hope that i'm at least
honest enough that if this was happening
in the other direction i would still be
talking about it
because if we don't have voter integrity
we don't have anything right if we don't
believe
that when you go in there you press that
button you pull that lever you punch
that thing that that actually counts it
counts
one time when you do it and that then is
tallied with everyone else's votes and
that's what gets us
to the end of an election and that that
system works and that's
how we have democrats sometimes and
republicans sometimes and hopefully
we'll have other parties in the future
and everything else
that the integrity of the system works
and matters if we don't have that we
really don't have anything else
so i think it's worth looking at these
things and i would love to you know what
in in the reuben report uh community if
you go to reubenreport.com i'll be
talking to you guys about it all day
long you can jump in there
comment in the youtube comment section
as well you guys have some discussions
about it maybe you have some insight
maybe some of you
are election officials or maybe some
we've got some data scientists out there
who knows but something does seem kind
of fishy
and the fact that so many people just
refuse to talk about it
makes the fish stink just a little bit
more
okay let's move on to the to the next
segment let's get away from from the
election and covid for a minute and talk
about racism
okay because the election's one thing
that's not really a problem kobe that's
not really a problem
racism it's here everyone's racist and
they're coming to get you well in the
san diego unified school
district they are now forcing teachers
to attend
white privilege training sessions so
we're going to throw up some of the
images here
it's just incredible the first image
that we've got here this is
land acknowledgement and this is what
they are teaching teachers to then teach
the students
in san diego we acknowledge that we meet
on stolen land taken from indigenous
peoples i am speaking to you
from kumaye land we must acknowledge the
hidden history of violence against
indigenous peoples
in an effort to move towards justice
it goes on to talk about the book white
fragility as you know this this book
white fragility which is being pushed
everywhere
and has been debunked a gajillion times
i would recommend
you check out james lindsay's twitter
feed james lindsey who i've had on the
show before
what are some of the things we should
know about white fragility well emotions
racial stress that are stirred when
making white people consider
racial realities because white people
freak out if you say something to white
people
guilt anger apathy frustration
close-mindedness and defensiveness those
are all things that white people have
white fragility prevents us from having
a racial dialogue
actually all we do seemingly is talk
about race we haven't had to build
racial stamina from rarely having
conversations about race again we just
constantly talk about race
turns race into the r word all right
it's a powerful means of white racial
control
and the protection of white advantage
let's just come back to me for a second
here
again i just want to be very clear about
something if you live in the united
states in 2020 no one cares what your
skin color is
no one cares what your gender is and no
one cares what your sexuality is are you
a decent person can you work hard
if you can do that you're probably going
to find a job you're probably going to
find
some happiness you're probably going to
find a partner in a community and the
rest of it
teaching that whiteness is inherently
evil
teaching that white people are there to
oppress people which is not only
untrue but is but as a true perversion
of all of the goodness of america that
was largely founded by white people who
expanded rights for everybody
uh it's it's actually just evil so then
they go on
uh to talk about how to be an
anti-racist and as i've been saying for
quite some time
it's the anti-racists actually these
days that are being the racists
well how can you be an anti-racist you
can confront and examine your white
privilege now that's very strange to me
because of an awful lot of white people
grow up in poverty i think more than
black people
but i guess they're white privileged
when they're growing up in in those
trailer parks acknowledge when you feel
white fragility happening
for you and slow down so you can listen
learn and act
behave white person otherwise you're a
racist be active
join and give to the community if you
give them enough money they might be
nice to you
teach others to see their privilege read
and educate yourself
use your privilege examine norms and
policies in your school and
classroom learn the history of other
ethnic groups than your own
we all do that that's what america is
all about we're a melting pot
we're a melting pot and we know the
stories and we do learn the stories and
we
actually i think most people appreciate
the stories right
i have friends of all different
backgrounds and they come they all came
from different places meaning their
ancestors came from different places
with different foods
and traditions and all of those things
and that is the stuff that we actually
celebrate in america that
that's the idea of america it's a
beautiful thing i don't you know and by
the way most of these teachers
are probably lefties so apparently
they're all the racists that need to be
taught all these things
uh then the next uh little piece here
you were upholding racist ideas
structures and policies that seems like
a
pretty broad stroke to say that all the
teachers are
doing all of that and then let's jump
over this is from reason.com
uh because it's just absolutely insane
they did a little deeper dive into all
of this
and district officials evidently believe
that the practice of grading
students based on their average score is
racist
and that an active effort to dismantle
racism
necessitates a learning environment free
of the pressure
to turn in assignments on time okay
let's just think about that for a second
grades which are completely impartial
right you take a test
it doesn't matter what your skin color
is what your gender is what your
sexuality is
you take a test and that test is usually
a pretty good barometer
barometer of whether you know what
you're talking about or not and then
if you do well on that test you can
start learning more stuff and then you
can move on to the next course
that all really makes sense and that's
how things have always been done
but now because of racism certain people
based on the color of their skin
that would be too much pressure for them
so they shouldn't have to
turn in assignments when other people
should have to turn in assignments does
that
really make sense is that going to make
those people work harder
or achieve more or is that the soft
bigotry of low expectations i mean think
about it for yourself
it goes on under the new system students
will not be penalized for failing to
complete
assignments so you don't even have to
complete them you can turn them in late
and you don't have to complete them
the grades they receive upon completion
of a course will no longer reflect their
average test
and assignment scores that is the
scariest line i have ever read
their grades they receive upon
completion of a course will no longer
reflect their average test and
assignment scores
really think about that so what would we
be grading students on
in san diego i thought la was the
stupidest place well actually i thought
sam
well technically i thought portland well
seattle it's hard to say which the
stupidest place is okay
san diego you're you're making a move
you know and that's tough
that's tough to make a move stupider
than portland san francisco seattle and
los angeles okay
that ain't easy congratulations san
diego what is the purpose
of going to school i think i'm old
school
i know i'm old school i thought that
going to school is about learning stuff
right you don't know some stuff and then
you learn some stuff
because there are people before you who
know some stuff and they learn some
stuff and then they can teach it to you
and then you can go on and continue into
the world this
systematic they love talking about
systemic racism
this systemic dumbing down of people
saying you're from this so we must treat
you differently
it's it's anti-american but also try to
really play this out where does this end
up so you're going to say to certain
people
okay you don't have to turn in your
things on time you don't even have to
complete your assignments and your grade
won't have anything to do with your test
scores well okay so now this kid gets an
a
right this kid gets an a by the way this
is no fault of this kid
okay he's just in the system right this
is this is why this is actually systemic
so now this kid gets an a he didn't
finish the projects
he didn't hand things in you know got a
22
on the test doesn't matter now he gets
into a better school than the kid who
worked hard and did all of the stuff
because that
poor schmuck is white so now that kid
gets doesn't get into the school the
other kid gets into the better school
the other kid gets into the better grad
school the other kid gets
into the better program after college
whatever it is
you see why we're gonna we're we're
actually going to reward
all of the worst things so if you think
that society is dumb right now if you
think we're at the beginning of
idiocracy
well then we will be in idiocracy too it
gets more idiotic
in about 10 years because what we will
do is we will raise people
based on things that have nothing to do
with knowing anything and then
imagine this dear person if you knew
that the person who was flying
your plane had bad grades in school or
didn't do well in school but then the
grades didn't reflect that their grades
just reflected their imputable
characteristics and then they were able
to get into flying school because of
that and everything else would you want
that person to be flying your plane let
me ask you something if you were having
heart surgery
would you care about the color of that
person's skin or would you just want the
person who was the best heart doctor
again i'm old school i don't care if my
doctor is black or white or gay or
straight or trans or anything else
do you know how to do the procedure if
you can do that procedure and you do it
well and you've got a good track record
you know what you're doing
you can perform that procedure on me but
we are going to create a system
where people who don't know what they
are doing will be elevated and people
who do know what they are doing
will be punished for it i don't like
that system i know
i know i i'm a radical again i'm a
freedom radical
and i'm a radical when it comes to
education it's it's very weird
anyway good luck san diego and
congratulations now san diego has to be
mentioned in the same sentence as
la san francisco seattle and portland
michael here is from san diego and he's
he's just nodding he's crying
he's oh no i mean just kidding nobody's
here with me in my house at the moment
just kidding eric garcia and again
to even imply that i would be having a
party at my house tonight is just
absolutely insane so i don't even know
why anyone would say that all right one
more thing as long as we're talking
about
eric garcetti our buffoon mayor here in
los angeles who
let's not forget just a few months ago
was out on the streets with protesters
without a mask and now he's locking us
all down and cancel
everything and don't walk your jog and
don't ride a bike and everything else
which by the way pretty much everyone is
ignoring
because people are good and sane uh this
video was taken
in l.a yesterday i i posted it and it
went totally viral i didn't know where
it came from originally
i'm told that don jr donald trump jr
posted on his instagram originally but
it's not credited so if someone knows
who posted this video
i would love to credit you and we'll
we'll do it in the comments if someone
can let me know
but this is a video from kitson's in
west hollywood kitson's if you're not
from la i think it's only an la store
it's sort of like a high-end urban
outfitters kind of funky you know they
got all the graphic tees all that stuff
well as far as i know the stores are
closed right now but they put up this
spectacular
spectacular display of protest
for the good people of los angeles take
a look
all right i don't have to add anything
to that it's just spectacular
we're seeing more and more of these
videos more
good decent hard-working americans who
are
fighting back who are
protesting and resisting in any way that
they see fit and they're doing it
peacefully by the way right like none of
the
mean trump supporters or the
anti-lockdown people or any of this
are doing it violently they're trying to
go about their lives and do it the best
way possible that that's a beautiful
thing and that's like art like that's
actually a true art
like when's the last time you saw some
art that really moved you when's the
last time you listened to a new song
that moved you or watched a new show
that moved you it's pretty rare these
days we're you know as this system
sort of grinds into this this sort of
awful post-modern thing that we're in
right now i have been thinking about
this a lot
like we need new stories we need new art
we need new things that can say
something to us that actually says
something
and it's a pretty beautiful thing uh so
that's it for today i realized i did not
put on my fake glasses
but you know i am trying my fake news
man glasses that is
i am trying to uh i'm not gonna curse
today i'm not gonna call out any of the
uh
of the politicians directly so i will
tell you this though
uh watch part three of my discussion
with douglas murray it just went up this
morning and of course you can watch the
full episode totally ad free
at reubenreport.com
and have a good day everybody